today on the matt walsh show the
attorney general of new york is going
after the nra seeking to dissolve it
for its alleged criminal conduct and
that brings up a good question
why hasn't any republican ag done this
to planned parenthood
speaking of criminal conduct also five
headlines including joe biden
accidentally being racist again
plus another actress issues a tearful
public apology but the reason for this
apology
uh is possibly the most absurd yet which
is quite a statement i realize
all of that on the way but we start here
uh yesterday as mentioned the attorney
general of new york made an announcement
a word of this impending announcement
made its way to the internet the day
before and leftists were beside
themselves with glee hoping that it
would be an announcement that
donald trump was going to be arrested
yes that's really what they thought was
going to happen
what they got instead perhaps wasn't
quite as good as that
if you're a leftist but still still a
nice treat i suppose
uh take a listen just a few minutes ago
my office filed a lawsuit against the
national rifle association
to dissolve the organization in its
entirety
for years of self-dealing and illegal
conduct
that violate new york's charities law
and undermine its own mission yes
dissolve the nra that's what she's
trying to do months out from an election
dissolve the end right call me cynical
but this seems to be just a tad
political just a tad maybe
that's all just a ted now here's more
from an npr report says attorney general
leticia james
claims in a lawsuit filed thursday that
she found financial misconduct in the
millions of dollars and that it
contributed to a loss of more than 64
million
over a three year period the suit
alleges that top nra executives misused
charitable funds for personal gain
awarded contracts to friends and family
members and provided contracts to former
employees to ensure loyalty
seeking to dissolve the nra is the most
aggressive
sanction that james could have sought
against the not-for-profit organization
which uh james has jurisdiction over
because it's registered
in new york and that's why she's thinks
she can dissolve the entire organization
james is a wide range of authorities
relating to non-profits in the state
including
the authority to force organizations to
cease operations or dissolve
the nra is all but certain to contest it
the nra said in a statement
that the legal action was political
i i think i i think they're probably
right about that calling it a baseless
premeditated attack on organization
and the second amendment freedoms it
fights to defend we not only
uh will not shrink from this fight we
will confront it and prevail
now i have no real opinion personally
about whether the nra is guilty of these
things or not
i certainly am not going to take the
word of the democrat attorney general of
new york nor of the media
when it comes to this but you know i
don't know i don't know what they've
done or haven't done
what i will say is this first of all new
york
particularly new york city is overrun
with crime and violence crime and
violence
have risen dramatically in recent months
and are still rising
okay it's only getting worse and it's
it's been very bad it's only getting
worse
here's just to give you an idea here's
the latest monthly report from the nypd
has found on
nyc.gov on the new york city
government's website
it says for the month of july 2020 there
was a 177 percent
increase in the number of shooting
incidents across the city as the number
of shootings rose in all five boroughs
of new york
the number of people murdered city-wide
increased 59
for the month while the number of
burglaries include increased 31 percent
and the number of auto thefts increased
53 percent
and we should note that much of this has
to do
directly with failures of the justice
system that is
with things the attorney general could
help fix and ought to be focused on
fixing
many of the violent criminals wreaking
havoc on the street are only out on the
street to begin with
because they've been released by the
courts and permitted to continue their
campaigns of terror
in these communities for example a
brooklyn gang member was released
without bail on an attempted murder
charge
and as soon as he got back into the
community he proceeded to participate in
three
drive-by shootings and here's just
here's the image from one of those
um he did he did three drive-by
shootings after already being in jail on
attempted murder charge
shot the guy in the back okay so clearly
a man of true courage
that we have here and this kind of thing
is not uncommon
the point is that the attorney general
ought to have other things on her mind
other things to do besides
act out this vendetta against the nra
but this is how democrats
operate they are simply not interested
in the practical fulfillment of their
actual job duties
this is this is why democrat-run cities
across the country are in shambles
least of all are they interested in
silly things like protecting their
communities and defending the innocent
against violent
criminal scumbags no they are interested
in their ideology and in acting
according to
their ideology and in staying loyal to
the ideology at all costs no matter what
this of course makes them bad leaders
but one thing that uh
i can say about them is that for the
most part they really believe what they
say they believe
and they will act on it or try to
anyway and this offers a stark contrast
to republicans who in most cases don't
seem to believe a single word of what
they say
which is why they rarely try to actually
enact conservative policies
or accomplish conservative goals if they
were interested in doing
the right thing and the right thing
capital r and lowercase r
then they would be going after planned
parenthood the same way the left is now
going after the nra
dissolve the nra well well whether
there's been fraud or whatever in the
organization i have no idea what i do
know
is that the nra has never directly
killed anybody
despite the way they're portrayed
planned parenthood on the other hand
kills over 300 000 humans a year
300 000 humans a year and they do it
with the help of a half a billion
dollars in tax money
why don't we dissolve them planned
parenthood should be harassed
and pursued constantly by conservatives
um the way that the nra is by leftists
planned parenthood certainly deserves it
and that is
to put the matter i think quite mildly
now you can argue that yes they kill 300
000 human children a year
and are thus one of the most evil and
destructive organizations to have ever
existed on planet earth but sadly
it's legal so there's no basis to
dissolve them or
pursue them as a criminal organization
well
don't worry planned parenthood commits
plenty of crimes too
crimes against humanity like the mass
murder of children
and also crimes according to the law
books planned parenthood has committed
fraud which is why planned parenthood
gulf coast had to pay 4.3 million
dollars in a lawsuit after being accused
of
fraudulently fraudulently billing
medicaid over the course of several
years
uh that's a crime we talk about fraud
well there you have it
planned parenthood employees across the
country have also been caught on
undercover video
multiple times over the years expressing
a willingness to turn a blind eye to
rape and sex
trafficking as was revealed for just one
example in a 20
2018 live action investigation
and of course speaking of undercover
videos planned parenthood executives and
other employees were
documented on tape extensively
by the center for medical progress and
dave deliden across many locations
trying to sell the butchered body parts
of their human victims
that happened it is on video
you can see it for yourself the videos
were not doctored
they were not deceptively edited they
were not they show what they show and
what they show
is both horrific and criminal
has the nra ever dismembered a child and
tried to sell its liver for profit to a
science lab
if so i say dissolve them immediately
i'll be i'll be the first to stand and
applaud
as you do it but i don't think they've
done that um
planned parenthood has not to mention
again we can't forget the millions and
millions and millions millions of human
beings that this organization
this organization from the bowels of
hell
have murdered for profit yet they
continue unimpeded not just unimpeded
but funded funded and i'll have more to
say about that aspect of it the funding
in just a second but first a word from
um
our friends at lifelock you know
cyber criminals are out there and uh
they're always trying to get your
information
and um they don't they don't they don't
take a break just because there's a
pandemic in fact quite the opposite
they're gonna take advantage of the
pandemic a criminal scheme involving
nearly 50
000 falsified unemployment insurance
claims have been discovered by maryland
state officials
the scam adds up to more than 500
million dollars in claims
while it is uh capitalizing upon the
hardships caused by covet the fraud
involved identity theft
from previous security breaches and
maryland isn't alone other states are
experiencing similar unemployment fraud
and that's why you know you have all
this information out there
your information is exposed if you're
using
the internet and uh and that's why you
have to do the responsible thing take
care of yourself
take care of your family uh you know
which is which can also be exposed
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet and you could miss
certain identity threats by just if
you're just monitoring your credit or or
something like that
and thinking that you're taking care of
everything there's a lot that you're
going to miss
and that's why there is lifelock
lifelock detects a wide range
of identity threats like your social
security number for example being on
sale
on the dark web if they detect your
information uh they will send you an
alert and you will know
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own join now and save
up 25
off your first year go to lifelock.com
waltz that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off all right so
planned parenthood um
on top of everything it's it's not just
that they are
allowed to continue doing these things
uh and it's not just that republicans
allow it to continue
but that they are funded in doing it
that what they are doing is funded by
tax money half a billion dollars
a year goes to them and
republicans are
responsible for that in part that played
an important role in that
i want you to imagine something for a
second imagine for a second
that the nra was funded to the tune of
half a billion dollars a year by the
government
imagine half a billion dollars a year
from the government going to the nra
now if if
if let's say that were that were
happening and then
democrats were to take control of the
house senate and white house
how long do you think it would take them
to defund the nra and pass a law
forbidding any future funding
how long would it take 30 seconds a
minute five minutes
at most it would be the very first thing
they did
and they would do it easily okay
and yet planned parenthood
500 million dollars a year for decades
now republicans take control of the
house senate white house
and just continue doing it do they have
their excuses of course
which every once in a while most of the
time they don't even bother offering an
excuse because nobody asks them
um they can just defy their campaign
promises and reveal themselves to be
total cowards and frauds
and there are no consequences at all
doesn't even come up so they don't have
to offer an excuse but if they're asked
about it they do have their issues oh
the democrats were stopping us
the democrats who had no power were
stopping us we couldn't do it
we just it's not our fault it's their
fault
they could have done it they chose not
to um which meant that
you know it's not just that democrats
are funding planned parenthood and
republicans aren't stopping it it's that
republicans were funding them
republicans chose to pass budgets
funding
taking money from you and giving it to
planned parenthood
uh and that is the essential difference
between republicans and democrats
that right there you look at you look at
the way the democrats
treat the nra okay they say that the nra
is evil and is responsible for millions
of deaths
they're not right about that they're
wrong but the way that they actually act
towards that organization you could tell
they really believe it
republicans would say the same thing
about the planned parenthood and in this
case they're actually correct
yet they don't act that way towards the
organization they say oh they're killing
babies and they're selling body parts
here's half a billion dollars a year
go go enjoy other evil organization
speaking of frauds the biggest one of
all right there
all right let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get into the headlines here
you know if you if you need auto parts
uh if you got to fix something on your
car or your truck or any other vehicle
uh you can go to the auto parts store
but why do that just go to rockauto.com
it's so much easier than walking into a
store and someone demanding quick
answers to questions that you might not
know an answer to
and even if they do you know they're
going to end up going online ordering
the part because they're not going to
have it it's a limited supply
rockauto.com is at your desk it's in
your pocket you carry it with you all
you all the time which means that you
have
in your pocket all the time essentially
uh millions of different
auto parts rockauto.com so it must be
really big pockets you have i suppose
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on
what they think the market will bear or
what they think they can sort of get out
of you they're not going to do that
rockauto.com look it's a family business
an honest business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com the shop uh for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low
and they're the same for professionals
and do-it-yourselfers so you don't have
to spend
twice as much for the same parts why do
that twice as much for the same parts
twice as much sometimes for
for a worse more limited selection the
rockhunter.com catalog is unique
easy to navigate quickly see all the
parts available for your car
truck and choose the brand
specifications and prices that you
prefer
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available
for your car or truck right walsh in
there how did you hear about this box so
that they know that
we sent you all right number one you've
probably heard this by now but let's
play it again anyway just for old time's
sake
what you all know but most people don't
know
unlike the african-american community
with notable exceptions the latino
community is an incredibly diverse
community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
yes there is joe biden suggesting for
a very inconceivable reason
that black people are a monolith and
they all think exactly the same
now he posted a statement last night
clarifying those remarks but the
clarification doesn't really clarify
anything this is what he says
earlier today i made some comments about
diversity in the african-american and
latino communities that i want to
clarify
in no way did i suggest or did i mean to
suggest
that the african-american community is a
monolith not by identity not
not on issues not at all throughout my
career i have witnessed the diversity of
thought background and sentiment
within the african-american community
it's this diversity that makes our
workplaces communities and country a
better place my commitment to you is
this i will always listen i will never
stop fighting for the african-american
community
and i will never stop fighting for a
more equitable future
see that's not really a clarification
because he didn't explain just exactly
what he was trying to say with his
original comment that's what a cl
clarification clarifies it makes clear
what was said before
um but it doesn't that doesn't do it
because what he said in the original
comment
was unambiguous he straight up said that
the black community is not diverse he
was he was he was claiming that all
black people think alike
this is not the first time he said that
remember famously he said that if you
don't vote for him you ain't black
okay this is a common theme that he goes
back to
and it need it doesn't even need to be
said but i'll say it anyway just
imagine the reaction if donald trump
said
any of that okay donald trump is
constantly accused of saying racist
things uh
i can't think of an example of something
that that donald trump has
actually said publicly is confirmed to
have said
that approaches uh
just these two examples in terms of
racism i i can't think of anything that
gets near it
speaking of donald trump by the way um
president trump
came out yesterday also with an attack
on biden
that i thought was pretty notable let's
let's listen to that
no religion know anything hurt the bible
hurt
god he's against god he's against guns
he's against energy our kind of energy
i just love the pause there hurt the
bible
hurt god
he's gonna hurt god he's gonna kick god
in the shins
and stomp on his foot hurting
uh i i i see this i you know i think
about yesterday
where you had biden out there saying
that black people all think the same
and then trump's saying that biden's
trying to hurt god and i see that and i
i get really sad and i'll tell you why i
get sad because i i think of what we're
missing
by not having a real campaign season
because this isn't a real campaign
season we're not we're probably
we're almost certainly not gonna have
debates they're not doing uh campaign
speeches they're not out and about you
know doing all of that
uh especially biden is not so it's not a
real campaign can you imagine though
if if we had a real campaign season with
these two
how hilarious it would be it's already
pretty funny
even without it but if if these guys
were out in front of people every day
giving speeches speaking live
and constantly upping the ante and
throwing accusations at each other
that would be spectacular and we are
missing that
i think what we saw yesterday was just a
shadow of what could have been it was a
it's a little
morsel of what could have been had we
if we had a real campaign season um
i mean you could always argue of course
that it's not actually funny at all
because this is the future of our
country at stake but
we're we are very much in a laugh or cry
situation
and so uh sometimes i choose to laugh
because crying on camera would be
rather unseemly number two hundreds of
teachers gathered in new york yesterday
to protest plans to reopen
let's take a look at uh that scene
yes they were carrying a coffin there
was also a guillotine
coffins and guillotines is is what they
brought
now if it were up to me we would just
fire all of these
pathetic useless cowards
you're marching through the street with
a coffin weeping
because you have to go back to work
after five months
my god you pitiful clowns
and you know something i guarantee that
every single one of those people
every single one they've all been to
target
they've all been to fast food
drive-throughs
many other businesses they've ordered
amazon pickup
you know something tells me i i don't
think they've been living
uh by you know self-sustaining gardening
and and maybe
going for hunts in the woods i i don't
think that's how i think they've
probably been living a relatively normal
life
as much as possible so the point is they
have no problem
with those employees being back at work
the target cashier they got no problem
with her being working
they have no problem with sending the
target employees to the guillotine by
their own logic
they're fine with that but them they
have to work
them oh no they're teachers you can't
make them
work they they're they're these are
hallowed sainted heroes
hallowed saints and heroes that don't
want to go to work and uh and and
provide an education because they're
scared
real heroic so i guess i should issue my
own clarification i said that they the
teachers were protesting reopening
now they weren't protesting reopening
anything but schools they're fine with
everything else being open
and everybody else working just not them
because they're special
number three the actress maddie ziegler
who i've never
heard of but apparently well she's an
actress
she has now apologized for racially
insensitive videos that she made
and she said in her apology quote i know
some of you are hurt
and may not accept my apology and then
she also said she
was uh ashamed and truly sorry and she
goes on apologize a lengthy statement
apologizing
and this is why i should probably
mention that she's apologizing
for supposedly racist videos that she
made
when she was nine years old nine
she is 17 now so that was eight years
ago at the age of nine
she made quote racially insensitive
videos and now has been forced to
apologize
all i'm going to say about that is if
you
as an adult have ever been hurt
by insensitive comments from a
nine-year-old
then you need to consult a psychologist
about your undiagnosed mental illnesses
assuming now maybe maddie z i don't know
anything about this maybe she
just on her own decided to come out an
apology if so then then fine but if this
was precipitated
by any sort of pressure from anybody who
had their
feelings hurt by eight videos from eight
years ago of a nine-year-old
then uh yes i i would say seek seek
psychological care
okay number four a few days ago i showed
you that picture of jerry falwell jr
liberty university president uh on a
yacht with his pants unzipped and his
shirt pulled up
standing with a woman who had her pants
unzipped and had her shirt pulled up
and they he appeared to be holding an
alcoholic beverage
and um and it all sort of appears to be
not exactly the kind of thing that the
president of a conservative christian
school
would want to especially could serve a
christian school that expels kids for
drinking and acting just like is
portrayed in that photo
not the kind of thing he'd want to post
on social media but he did post it and
then he took it down but of course it
was too late
now a couple days later this clip
but i'll play for you in a second
supposedly of jerry falwell jr
calling into a morning radio show and
explaining himself started making the
rounds
and i swear to you i heard this thing
and i really assumed right away
that it was fake that it was some kind
of morning radio you know
morning zoo gag or something or someone
calling in pretending to be falwell
but apparently according to politico and
other outlets this is real this is
really falwell
and this is actually from a news talk
radio radio show in
lynchburg virginia where liberty
university is located
and it's also a longer interview where
he talks about other random things so
yes this appears to be
actually real this is actually falwell
jr calling in
and this is what he has to say listen to
this what was up with that picture on
instagram you know it was weird because
she could
she was she's pregnant so she couldn't
get her she couldn't get her pants
dipped
and i was like trying to like
my i had a pair of jeans that i haven't
worn in a long time so i couldn't get
mine zipped either
and so i just put my belly i just put my
belly out like hers
and it was just um she's my wife's
assistant and she's
a sweetheart and i should never put up
embarrassed her because um
anyway i i've apologized to everybody
and i promised my kids i'm gonna try to
be better i'm gonna try to be a
good boy from here on out okay he he
sounds
extremely intoxicated to me is it just
me or or
does he not sound very drunk in that
on a weekday morning calling into a
radio show
he sounds very drunk to me i don't know
if he is
i can't say that but he really sounds it
to me
i mean i'm going to be a good boy
this is a 58 year old president
of the most prominent supposedly
conservative christian school in america
after that photo he calls in a few days
later
i'm going to be a good boy
i couldn't get my pants zipped up that
this is how he responds
and this again is the president of a
christian university
it's it's embarrassing
and they have a board of trustees at
liberty university they need to dump
this guy they need to get rid of him
because he's an embarrassment to the
school
and to the christian faith and always
has been to be honest with you
uh and he's just a disgrace and he needs
to go
all right number five stan van gundy
former nba coach current nba announcer
uh posted this to twitter trying to
justify speaking of a disgrace the nba
submission to china
uh and their silence in the face of
chinese atrocities
this is what he said he said we
committed genesis we committed genocide
against native americans
we have enslaved lynched segregated and
incarcerated blacks over 400 years
women couldn't vote for 140 years using
abuses elsewhere to try to distract from
our own poor record on human rights
is dishonest now of course the irony
here is that he is
he's saying others are using abuses
elsewhere to distract from things
happening
he's using abuses from hundreds of years
ago to distract from
abuses that are happening right now
today
um in in china but
all i really wanted to say here is you
know he says we committed genocide
against native americans we've enslaved
and lynched
uh black people well
what i'd say to stan van gundy is listen
stan
uh if you have committed those crimes
then you need to turn yourself into the
authorities immediately i i appreciate
you
confessing to it and accepting some
accountability but the real
accountability for you
as some i mean you're confessing here
you said that you said we that includes
yourself so you've said that you have
committed genocide
and you've enslaved and lynched people
uh
you you need to contact the fbi and turn
yourself in immediately
now me personally i've never done any of
those things
i haven't done anything close to any of
those things
nobody in my family has even done any of
those things
so i am 100 innocent of all of those
crimes
i don't know who the we is here it
certainly isn't me
so you're you're being a little bit uh
you're so there's some you're being
vague i'm not exactly sure
but but whoever it is whoever your
accomplices are in this i
you all need to turn yourselves in and
face justice
um so that's that's all that's all i can
say about that that is a that is a
stunning admission and confession from
stan van gundy i'm surprised it's not
getting more
more coverage we're gonna go to our
daily cancellation but first i want to
tell you about our most exclusive
membership tier over daily wire which is
all access all access memberships
features behind the scenes access to
live streams and discussions with your
podcast hosts myself included as well as
early or sometimes
exclusive access to daily wire products
as part of that we launched our brand
new limited count collector's edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bat company
only 100 bats were made engraved with
the individual number in which they were
produced
uh from one to one hundred now this is
the crazy part these bats were only
offered to all access members and they
were sold out in two days
so if you don't want to miss out on
exclusive products and offers you should
really join all access at the daily wire
you'll also get exclusive access to live
online discussions with hosts writers
and special guests along with joining
all access live
our exclusive live stream q and a's
hosted every night
uh lastly you get not one
not one but two i don't have a second
one here
uh not one but two
leftist tears tumblers with your
membership so go to dailywire.com
mulch and my last name is mulch
dailywire.com
walsh with coupon code all access to get
20 off
your membership they call me mulch what
can i say
finally for our daily cancellation uh
just a quick one today
as we uh as we get into into the weekend
uh or quick
two actually both of these are defensive
reverse cancellations which is something
that i do every once in a while
it's somewhat of a rare spectacle it's a
rare treat the cancellation deflection
i'm going to be canceling those in the
audience who have tried to cancel me
for some of the things i've said this
week on the show
primarily i'm going to cancel the people
who wanted to cancel me
for our discussion earlier in the week
about voting
and i said if you heard that show and if
you didn't hear the show because you
weren't listening then you're canceled
for that
but i said that the problem with voting
is not that the turnout is too low it's
it's it's it's that the turnout is too
high
too many people are doing it there
should be fewer voters not more
voting should be more difficult not
easier
voting should be a privilege exercised
by the qualified
not a universal right given to any
non-contributing [ __ ] who happens to
wander into a polling station uh on on
on a particular day or send in a ballot
via mail now i guess
now obviously people were upset about
this for many reasons but the the main
thing
the main group i want to cancel actually
are the people the conservatives
who told me and i got this a lot that i
might be right
and it might be true that we should have
laws in place ideally excluding
unproductive and ignorant members of
society from voting
but we shouldn't be talking about that
this is not a discussion we should be
having right now because it's not
popular
it's not politically expedient and so
it's it's a dumb thing to be
arguing for or bringing up it's those
people
with that attitude especially who i'm
gonna cancel because
this is the theme of the show right
talking about the difference between
left and right
um here's here's another difference
leftists
they have big crazy ideas all the time
and and and they have no problem
articulating them and arguing for them
think about the green new deal okay and
we
on the right had a lot of fun with that
but
it's it's a smart move to put to put
that out there
to argue to argue for the most extreme
thing you can
and part of the part of the strategy
there is is if you argue for the most
extreme thing
then you settle on something that's
still pretty extreme but not as extreme
it seems like a compromise it seems like
you're being reasonable
but i think the real point of it is to
is to get the idea out there
that's what leftists do they get the
idea the ideals out there
they make the argument for what they
ideally think
society should look like this is what
leftists are talking about all the time
we know what their ideal society looks
like
it's pretty horrific and dystopian
uh not a society that i want to live in
but it's a society that we're becoming
and part of the reason for that is
because they have a clear vision
for every aspect and facet of society
and they say this is what it ought to be
i think conservatives often counter that
with no vision
what exactly if you're you're if you're
a conservative what do you think society
should look like
how should all these things you know
don't tell me what you think it will
look like or what's what's the most
practical most reasonable thing to to
strive for or the most reasonable goal
but no no
in your ideal world what does it look
like what is your ideal
vision the left has their ideal vision
and they put it up against nothing
or just a whole bunch of practical
compromises that the right makes
so what i'm talking about here no do i
do i actually think with voting
that uh that any time soon there are
going to be these laws in place of
course not
but it's a good idea to have to to have
a vision
um for what voting
ideally would look like how it ideally
would operate
what it actually is what it's for i mean
that's what i'm getting at here
no this is i i'm not claiming that this
this is pr
practical uh advice or something that's
really going to happen anytime soon
but it's a question of what is voting
really what is it what do we even have
it for
once again the left they have their
answers to those sorts of questions
what is this for what are we supposed to
have this for they have an answer their
answers are wrong but they have it
the right doesn't have answers a lot of
the time
so what is voting for what's the point
of voting
is the point of voting just to give
literally
every single person a chance and every
single person no matter what
in america you know an equal say in in
in the direction of the country is
is was that the original idea is that
does that make sense
is that best for the country is that how
the country should work i say
no no i i
think voting is something that is a
is a great responsibility a great
privilege
but it's not for everybody
as i said if you are if you are ignorant
of the
basic facts of how our system works if
you don't know anything about that
you're not paying attention
if you're not a productive member of
society then it's not for you
the great thing is it could be for you
you those are all things you can change
anytime and if you do welcome
but until that time um
you should be voting that's it it's a
night it's an it is an
idealist sort of argument but those are
the kinds of arguments that we should be
making
and then finally uh what was the other
one that i was okay oh yeah
so slightly less important but i also
wanted to cancel the people who tried to
cancel me
yesterday because i had never heard the
term uh
thought and i'm still not sure if i'm
pronouncing it t-h-o-t
i still don't know if i'm pronouncing it
right i don't know if the h is supposed
to be silent or not but
t-h-o-t i encountered that yesterday on
the show had never heard of it
uh there were many people making fun of
me for that
many cancellation attempts personally
hurt my feelings first of all
but now i know that it means that ho
over there
and um you know when i when i heard that
i was pleasantly surprised because
and i you know i honestly couldn't sort
of
believe that the youth of today
have uh a gardening term like that
you know that they have gardening lingo
i i thought was uh was was pretty
impressive and gardening is a
uh a very fruitful pastime
so so i was pleasant i'm thinking i'll
probably go to lowe's
this weekend and drop that lingo on the
outdoor sales associate just so he knows
just so he knows that i'm you know
i'm hip all right uh so you're all
cancelled
and that's it we're gonna cancel the
show now at least for the least for the
week
have a great weekend everybody godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there